hello I'm Simon Pegg and I'm playing
Phineas nigellus black
Phineas black is at this point in the
story he's the Headmaster of Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry we saw
Phineas in the books and in the films he
was a portrait in um in Dumbledore's
office but this is at a time when he was
actually actively the Headmaster Phineas
nigellus black is the least popular
Headmaster in the history of Hogwarts
you are here to focus on your academic
endemic Futures he is a sort of pompous
disinterested you call that a shine on
those boots
he's not a good teacher or Headmaster in
any way I think he would have taken on
the role of Headmaster because of the
gig you know it's a prestigious position
I don't think he has any interest in
children's education or or being in any
way a role model it's not really his
concern what he wants is the Kudos of
being the Headmaster of the greatest
Wizarding School in the world I wonder
almost daily why I accepted this
appointment from the ministry yeah he's
just a bit of an idiot really has anyone
seen my ivory handled hand mirror no of
course you haven't
he is serious black Black's great great
grandfather I think I'm right in saying
that so there's got to be a little bit
of something fun in him
it's serious is not the product of the
black family seemingly he's very
different and Phineas nigelis is like
the opposite of Sirius Black he's not
Noble he's not brave he's just a
self-interested
fool
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we come across Phineas as a sort of help
and a hindrance to the players who are
working their way through the game head
must I'm with a student in my schedule
your schedule will wait indefinitely as
will your student he's entirely there to
um
Scupper the efforts of the player I'm
sure I haven't time for any of you at
the moment none none at all move aside
foreign
[Music]
the lessons I think the students and
players will get from Phineas nigellous
black is don't be like Phineas and
nigellus black he is not someone to
Aspire to he is a
self-involved cantankerous slightly
childish figure and I think be less like
Phineas is the message of this of the
game I said I'm sure you all have plenty
to do before classes begin tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
ly excited to be part of the Harry
Potter Universe I watched all those
movies and uh always expected a role
virtually every British actor actor has
been in the Wizarding World films apart
from me and so to get the role of
particular black one of the black family
that's uh that's a cool thing because
Sirius was always my favorite character
in the books so it feels really good it
feels like something's finally been put
right